[Music]  to entertainment  plenty of major performers coming to  town in a few weeks  country superstar brad paisley will make  his debut at the win  he's got two acoustic shows later in the  month at the encore  theater tickets go on sale friday  morning at 10 o'clock  singer adam lambert who's been  performing with queen announced his five  show engagement over at the venetian  they'll take the stage in october  tickets for  these shows also go on sale friday  morning at 10 o'clock  because of the demand for shows  spiegelworld's absinthe is expanding its  schedule  starting on the 4th of july it will  produce 16 shows a week for the first  time in its history here in town  masks by the way are now optional for  fully vaccinated guests and performers